this plans to bring more affordable
housing to the valley now on hold
neighbors are really divided over a
project to build a low-income community
near north decatur in the 215. madison
kimbrough heard from both sides after
sitting in on tonight's planning
commission meeting
the city asked the public their thoughts
and they responded the majority opposed
to having this low-income multi-family
development in their neighborhood as
they say the increase of crime and
congestion is of top concern the
276-unit facility would be located on
rome and decatur the nearly 9.5 acres of
land was provided to the city of las
vegas by the bureau of land management
marked solely to be used for affordable
housing and through a bidding process a
company called ovation won the bid thus
paying a dollar for legality purposes
and taking over the cost of construction
with a plan to manage the property for
15 years the majority of attendees at
city hall tonight opposed to the idea
while some of the few there believe a
lot of good can come from it
our number one concern is the high
density component and it's not the
income component it's the amount of
pressure that will be put in that exact
location
by traffic for schooling for
emergency responses it does improve the
neighborhood it increases property
values it actually lowers crime they've
got a lot of fears regarding affordable
housing it's people just like you and me
now in the end the city commissioners
voted on a 60-day hold and they will
revisit the discussion on september 13th
and while the environment tonight was
tense at times the majority were pleased
that the city decided to give it more
time before making a final decision in
the newsroom madison kimbrough live
local now